right we're going live now to the
constituency of Islington North in
London that's a constituency of the
leader of the main opposition party the
Labour Party Jeremy Corbyn and we
understand that he has just won it but
let's listen to the rest of the counts
writing or mark by which a voter could
be identified to being unmarked or
wholly void for uncertainty 188 the
turnout 71.8% and i hereby do declare
that the said Jeremy burner Corbin is
duly elected to serve as Member of
Parliament for Islington North
constituency I would like to invite
Jeremy to speak
[Applause]
thank you could I start by saying a huge
thank you to the returning officer and
all the staff and the police that have
ensured a fair and democratic election
has taken place today and also to
congratulate and thank my fellow
candidates for their participation in
this election and also a very heartfelt
thanks to the people of Islington Norse
for electing me again for the tenth time
to represent hissing to North in
Parliament I'm very very proud to do so
and I've learnt so much from the people
of Islington north and it's my pride in
my pleasure to continue to be their
representative in Parliament I also want
to thank Ruth Hayes our agent for this
election and all of the wonderful
friends comrades and supporters in
nursing to North Labor Party for the
huge effort they put in in this election
campaign and they put in all the time to
carry a message of hope and justice all
over our constituency and through me I
hope to a wider world the pressure on
those surrounding politicians is often
very very high indeed the media
intrusion on people's lives is very high
indeed and the attacks that take place
against family and loved ones of
politicians continue and they're
disgraceful and frankly they are
disgusting I want to take this
opportunity to thank my family my close
friends and those that have been close
by and been very supportive during this
and every other election campaign I want
to thank my three sons for the huge
support they give me and thank my wife
Lara Alvarez for all that she puts up
with because of the way in which the
media behaved towards me towards her and
indeed towards my party during this
election campaign and
a very disappointing night for the
Labour Party with the result that we've
got but I want to say this in the
election campaign we put forward a
manifesto of hope a manifesto of unity
and a manifesto that would help to right
the wrongs and the in justices and
inequalities that exist in this country
for those who need housing those who
need an effective health service that
will deliver for them and those children
that need a school that is properly
funded and they're not being taught in
oversized classes and a manifesto that
gave hope in dealing with the
environmental crisis the world faces by
investing for the future through a green
Industrial Revolution all of those
policies were extremely popular during
the election campaign and remain
policies that have huge popular support
all across this country
however brexit has so polarized and
divided debate in this country it has
overridden so much of a normal political
debate and I recognize that has
contributed to the results that the
Labour Party has received this evening
all across this country the issues of
social justice and the issues of needs
of people will not go away just because
brexit is dealt with in the way in which
Boris Johnson presumably plans to deal
with it at the moment all those issues
will come back center stage in the
debate and the fundamental labour
message about justice and equality
within our society is going to be one
that is there for all time because it's
the very core of what my party believes
in and what I will always advocate on
behalf of my constituents
see and on behalf of my party I want to
also make it clear that I will not lead
the party in any future general election
campaign I will discuss with our party
to ensure there is a process now of
reflection on this result and on the
policies that the party will take going
forward and I will lead the party during
that period to ensure that discussion
takes place and we move on into the
future because I'm very proud of the
trust that our half-million members put
in me to lead this party and I'm very
proud of the way that we fought this
election campaign we did not descend
into the gutter we did not undertake
personal abuse we undertook the task of
getting a message of hope and justice to
every part of this country and I'm very
grateful to the Labour Party in
Islington North for being very tolerant
of the fact that I didn't spend as much
time in this election campaign in
Islington as obviously I would want to
do because I've been travelling around
the whole country to ensure that Labour
message is put there but I want to say
this I will remain the MP for Islington
North and I'm proud to represent the
people of Islington north and I'm proud
in Parliament and outside that we will
forever continue the cause for socialism
for social justice and for society based
on the needs of all rather than the
greed of a few that is what makes our
party what it is and I'm very proud of
the achievements of our party in the
development of its manifesto and its
ideas and I tell you what those ideas
and those principles are eternal and
they will be there for all time I thank
the people of Islington North once again
for putting their faith and trust in me
I will work as I always have
just to represent and defend the people
of my constituency because they're very
special
and I owe them so much and they have all
taught me so much thank you very much
so the leader of the Labour Party Jeremy
Corbyn there successfully
keeps his seat keeps his sees he's
represented this seat isn't and nor for
about thirty six years or so this is the
tenth time he's been reelected but
nonetheless there he did announce that
he will not lead he will not lead the
party to through another election he'll
stay in post through a transition period
while a new leader is selected so Jeremy
Corbyn they're effectively resigning the
lead of the Labour Party but not
immediately Jonah Holly's our
correspondent in London and so no
surprise really that Jeremy Corbyn keeps
his seat but nonetheless having to
confront what is a devastating defeat er
a complete routing of his party yes
absolutely no surprise in Islington
North as you say the 10th time he's been
voted into that seat he's been an MP
since 1983 but surely this is a
devastating defeat more so than he could
have expected than the Labour Party
could have expected he does have to
confront that he's come out very quickly
to acknowledge it and to lay out some
sort of a future plan the questions have
been asked throughout the night what
happens to Jeremy Corbyn what happens to
Jeremy Corbyn there been some pretty
scathing indictments not least from a
former former Home Secretary's former
MPs who said it's all down to Corbin its
Corbin it's Corbin everything going on
here is Corbin and he is really the
central figure in this Labour Party what
the Labour Party has become under his
leadership he directs policy he directs
staffing it's all about Corbin now one
has to wonder whether this particular
plan that he's laying out saying that he
will go eventually he won't lead the
party into the next election but he
won't go immediately he will bide his
time some sort of period of reflection
whilst they consider their future
direction whether that will be enough
for a party now brew
used and battered and will almost
certainly from the early hours of
tomorrow morning or the later hours of
this morning start looking for someone
to blame let me bring in my guest mo who
sane a former advisor to David Cameron
in Downing Street also for homosexual
Terry amber Rudd no stranger of course
to the Internet's of politics mo how
does he hold off calls Jeremy Corbyn to
go immediately he's led his party to
what must be seen as a catastrophic
defeat exactly and I think it is gonna
be very hard for him to hold off these
calls you've already seen lots of
backbench Labour MPs calling for him to
go right now and I just don't think this
kind of half resignation in terms of our
won't lead the party in the next
election which is five years away is
going to be enough clearly there does
need to be a period reflection within
the Labour Party but I don't think
Jeremy Corbyn is the person who can lead
that because by all accounts the
anecdotal evidence shows people knocking
on the door is that his name was coming
up as he is actually a part of the
problem and what we've seen on the
conservative side and the labor side is
a presidential campaign it is really
about the personalities of Boris Johnson
one side and Jeremy Corbyn on the other
side so I think whether with him being
part of the issue you know it's his
campaign his policies and the people
around him people in the labour party
the moderates feel that he has moved the
party in too much of a harder left
direction than they want this for the
party they joined so I don't see how he
can oversee an effect do you mark his
own homework I don't think that's gonna
wash when you hear figures like John
McDonnell senior Labour Party Ally of of
mr. Corbyn saying look he's a reluctant
leader he's not going to overstay his
welcome then you have labour strategist
former labour strategist like John
McTernan who we spoke to a little
earlier saying he's so stubborn he will
probably cling on he's not even sure
that he recognises the issues and you
see in that stat that stubbornness in
his refusal to apologize for claims over
claims of anti-semitism his parent
even to acknowledge the extent of the
problem within the party that has been
so damning in this election campaign in
particular it is conceivable that he
could just soldier on regardless yes it
is and I think you will see a narrative
emerging from elements of the Labour
Party particularly the parts that
supports him there this is all about
bricks ooh so this is not about anything
else and certainly not about him but
it's about bricks there and the party's
slightly confused messaging on that
however I still go back to the point I
don't think that that is going to wash I
think he will try and certainly he and
his allies do you seem to have taken
over the different structures within the
Labour Party so the process to get rid
of him may still be difficult and when
you get into these positions I'm sure
people do kind of get used to you and
like the taste of power but you know he
has tried to sell this twice now to the
electorate and people are not buying his
version of Corbin ISM so I think he
should see the writing's on the wall and
for the sake of the party step down
okay well Sam we'll leave it there
Jeremy Corbyn off the back of a
disastrous night for the Labour Party
isn't stepping down yet but says he
won't lead his party into the next
election battle